[Musique]
ajoutez du plomb à l'essence pour rendre
les moteurs des véhicules plus
performant
si l'idée est révolutionnaire et surtout
bon marché elle s'avère catastrophique
pour la santé et l'environnement
l'ère de l'essence au plan s'amorce en
1922 c'était il ya cent ans
[Musique]
ingénieur chimiste de diablo motors
découvre qu'en ajoutant à l'essence du
thé trahit-il de plans on stoppe le
cliquetis du moteur le fameux cognement
qui avec le temps l'endommagent
le plan est pourtant un poison et on
sait depuis 2001 il provoque maladies
cardiaques accidents vasculaires
cérébraux et cancer il affecte même le
développement du cerveau en particulier
chez les jeunes enfants
deux ans après la mise en marché de
l'essence au plomb en 1924 médecin et
journaliste sonne l'alarmé il rapporte
l'empoisonnement et la mort d'ouvriers
dans une raffinerie
l'administrateur de la santé publique
américaine met en place un panel
d'experts
sa conclusion il n'ya aucune raison
d'interdire la vente d'essence au plan
il faut plutôt augmenter la protection
des ouvriers c'est l'essor des gaz
d'échappement chargés en plomb
si bien que dans les années 1966 presque
la totalité de l'essence vendue dans le
monde contient du plomb
mais au fil des ans de nouvelle preuve
de la nocivité du plomb s'accumulent
en 1979 on publie les conclusions d'une
étude chaque chez la femme enceinte
l'exposition à ce polluant peut réduire
le quotient intellectuel de l'enfant à
naître
à la suite de la publication les
restrictions du plomb dans les
carburants se multiplient dans les
années 1980 la plupart des pays riches
interdisent d'essence au plan mais la
majorité des pays pauvres continuent à
l'utiliser
afrique juillet 2021 les stations
services d'algérie termine d'écouler
leurs stocks d'essence aux plans
ce sont les dernières pompe à pouvoir en
vendre l'air de l'essence au plomb est
officiellement terminée